eh bien c'est tellement génial
[Musique]
elle est là partout euh ouais je vois que
tu t'es familiarisé avec
notre disque d'obéissance c'est une
de mes petites inventions d'ailleurs
tu sais que certaines personnes trouvent que c'est une sorte de
promenade érotique avec  moi je vais te dire
quelque chose disque d'obéissance je n'ai jamais été
fou de ce nom j'étais censé
être un espace réservé jusqu'à ce que je puisse penser à
quelque chose de mieux mais tout le monde a commencé
à les appeler obéissance je n'ai rien entendu
mais je n'étais pas  ceux comme des
étincelles de vos doigts comme des éclairs peuvent
être localisés votre cousin oh bien
ouais il est hé parce que nous n'avons presque pas
pu ne pas vous trouver ce qu'il cachait
mm-hmm alors je dois admettre ce que tu as fait
Carlo ce que tu as dit  ce n'était qu'un petit
chameau pourquoi l'avez-vous fait en tant que petit chameau
jouant au jeu Je ne sais pas ce que cela
signifie jouer avec le chameau camper
vous venez de dire qu'il campait non s'il
n'y a pas de survivant Le
camping est mauvais mais ce que vous faites vraiment
je jouais  blings de la mort Oh g  ambling c'est
bien hmm
Carlo je te pardonne
ils recommencent bien
qu'officiellement officiellement gracié de la vie
[Applaudissements]